the other day I was looking through old
photos of me as a kid and it struck me
how similar my dad and I actually are
for both quiet reserved I realized that
as a kid my dad was the most important
person in my life the best part of my
day was hearing the garage open my
brother and I would sprint toward the
door screaming as we jumped into his
arms and no matter how tired from work
he was he would pick us up pretending
with us that the floor was lava I wonder
if he wishes he could relive those
moments to the birthday parties the
camping trips trips the SeaWorld I think
it's natural for one's relationship with
their father to change over time
it starts slowly you begin to spend more
time with your friends you start to date
we avoid to college and before you know
it the only time that you're calling
your dad is when you start filing your
taxes or your car's making a weird noise
I guess somewhere along the way I became
my own person and then you begin to
wonder when was the last time that I
said I love you thank you for the
sacrifices you made to give me the best
life possible I guess he's just a phone
call away
hello hello father
I just wanted to tell you I love you and
thank you for all that you've done well
I love you too that makes me very happy
to know that you have fond memories and
that you really enjoyed spending time
with me I certainly enjoyed spending
time with you you're coming down on
Sunday for Father's Day yes okay what
time you think you'll come over um
probably like an afternoon okay